[Music]
spending a day with you and cube I would
have to say the hardest thing in the
world might be to get cube to break a
smile that guy is this guy look at this
face he doesn't samatha we were in a car
with him for an hour for two hours and
we everything he just does that look cuz
this looks at you
that's him laughing at a joke right
[Applause]
obviously I pride myself on on being
funny but not forced like sometimes it's
natural now when I have to be funny I
get it you know this takes where
everybody on it's on the set would be
dying Oh oh my god Kevin how just do it
and I was looking cube even just be
staring I'm like a man you need to laugh
everybody else because I know me let's
just get the work done what Tom you told
my say man I just want to know for me
you know why don't you laugh why don't
you break when everybody else breaks
he's like because I don't want to waste
tape what you don't want to waste tape
like what he said it with a straight
face and walked away as if I should go
oh
my nightmare would be doing comedy and
looking front row cube staring at me
with that face because I'm seeing that
so many times
Jackson booga-booga-booga it probably
goes back to his trailer and a single
tear
you